the term of police militarization I can
make military look bad because if people
think that police are looking like the
military that they assume that this
perverted form of police is what the
military looks like and it doesn't look
anything like what the military does
here are five lessons the police can
learn from the military when it comes to
crowd control you know there is a big
difference between our military and our
local law enforcement leaders and police
have to have an understanding on how
when and what degree to use force this
has only accomplished through extensive
training buying equipment is just the
beginning
often having equipment without training
is more dangerous and less effective
than having no equipment at all you know
there is a big difference between our
military and our local law enforcement
crowds are composed of real people
expressing a real grievance most
protesters are law-abiding citizens
exercising their fundamental right to
assembly they must be respected you know
there is a big difference between our
military and our local law enforcement
use open dialogue with protest leaders
as this often avoids misunderstandings
and results and protesters policing
themselves coercion of crowds on the
other hand rarely results in good
outcomes and often exacerbates the
unrest there is a big difference between
our military and our local law
enforcement police negotiate their
actions based on crowd behaviors a
nonviolent crowd warrants a non-violent
police response the unnecessary use of
tear gas and guns tends to add to crowd
panic and only increases rather than
decreases unrest if a crowd becomes
violent police should respond with the
least amount of force necessary you know
there is a big difference between our
military and our local law enforcement
recording everything in a civil
disturbance helps hold everyone
accountable for their actions
police and protesters alike in addition
to police recording themselves media
should not be treated as an enemy
stifling or oppressing the media only
gives the impression that the police are
trying to hide something if law
enforcement followed these five lessons
from the Army we would have safer
communities built on mutual trust
between the citizens and the police